so i had i had an fbi agent this last
week i don't know what his name was was
he fbi was he uh jim clementi jim
clemente really enjoyed the interview
phenomenal teacher of what they do he
was an fbi agent for 20-something years
his brother is an fbi agent as well so
both are fbi agents and then
his other brother peter does something
else he's private equity and they
started a company together and they're
doing good so here's what i did i played
a clip of
rand paul and fauci
because what this guy does for a living
is he sees what's the word he used he
his deception so his job is to see
deception okay he's an fbi agent like if
somebody's lying as somebody's lying
deception so i said you know i want i
want to do
let's profile somebody if it's okay with
you let's profile somebody
and we play this clip now know that he
is
and complete
not a fan of former administration okay
so i wanted to have trump's
uh zero like zero okay okay yeah zero so
he is a supporter of the curt
administration more than the prior
administration and i said i want to kind
of profile and kind of get your feeling
on this and tell me if you believe out
she's telling the truth or where he
stands with this can you play this clip
just play the clip let's watch for first
four minutes of it and maybe if you know
how to do the speed do me a favor click
on that do you know what that okay and
can you guys do 1.5 go to 1.5 not 2.0
1.5 because they all talk slow so press
play and let's let
ren make his argument first and then
when it comes to tony's answer slow it
down to 1.0 to really get the feeling
three weeks have you guys seen this or
not this is from three weeks ago you've
not seen this this is not i have not
okay open it up because you're about to
be blown away yeah right
their own reality show okay
click on this and just listen i don't
expect you today to admit that you
approved of nih funding for gain of
function research in wuhan but your
repeated denials have worn thin and a
majority of americans frankly don't
believe you even the nih now admits that
eco-health alliance did perform
experiments in wuhan that created
viruses not found
found in nature that actually did gain
in lethality the facts are clear the nih
did fund gain of function research in
wuhan despite your protestations you can
deny it all you want but even the
chinese authors of the paper in their
paper admit that viruses not found in
nature were created and yes they gained
in infectivity your persistent denials
though are not simply a stain on your
reputation but are clear and present
danger to the country and to the world
of the world as professor kevin esveldt
of mit has written gain of function
research looks like a gamble that
civilization can't afford to risk and
yet here we are again with you steadfast
in your denials why does it matter
because gain of function research with
laboratory-created viruses not found in
nature could cause a pandemic even worse
the next time we're suffering today from
one that has a mortality of
approximately one percent they're
experimenting with viruses that have
mortalities of between 15 and 50 percent
yes our civilization could be at risk
for these viruses
experiments that combine unknown viruses
with known pandemic causing viruses are
incredibly risky experiments that
combine unknown viruses with
coronaviruses that have as much as 50
mortality could endanger civilization as
we know it and here you sit
unwilling to accept any responsibility
for the current pandemic and unwilling
to take any steps to prevent gain of
function research from possibly
unleashing an even more deadly virus you
mislead the public by saying that the
published viruses could not be coveted
well exactly no one is alleging that no
one is alleging that the published
viruses by the chinese are covered what
we are saying is that this was risky
type of research gain of function
research it was risky to share this with
the with the chinese and that coveted
may have been created from a non-profit
environment we don't anticipate the
chinese are going to reveal the virus if
it came from their lab
you know that but you continue to
mislead you continue to support nih
money going to wuhan you can simply say
you trust the chinese scientist you
appear to have learned nothing from this
pandemic
will you today finally take some
responsibility for funding gain and
function research and move on pause it
pause it pause it first
pause it first now go to speed and i
just watch body language and listen
if you're telling the truth you're going
to know you don't have to
go press play with two masks in the
background he's a messed up extremely
safe senator with all due respect i
disagree with so many of the things that
you've said
again first of all gain of function
is a very nebulous term
we have spent not us but outside bodies
a considerable amount of effort
to give a more precise definition to the
entire shaken
of research that is of concern
that might lead to a dangerous situation
you think you are aware of that
that is called
co we're aware that you deleted gain of
function from the nih website well i can
get back to that a moment if we have
time
but let's get back to the operating
framework and guidewells of which we
operate under bad actors you have
ignored them
the guidelines are very very clear that
you have to be dealing with a pathogen
that clearly is shown and very likely to
be highly transmissible in an
uncontrollable way
in humans and to have a high degree of
morbidity and mortality and that you do
experiments to enhance
that hence the word e p p p
enhanced pathogens of potassium protect
but so when eco health alliance took the
virus
and combined it with wiv 1 and caused a
recombinant virus that doesn't exist in
nature and it made my sicker mice that
had humanized cells you're saying that
that's not gain of function research
according to the framework and
guidelines
so what you're doing is defining a way
gain of function you're simply saying it
doesn't exist because you changed the
definition on the nih website this is
terrible and you're you're completely
trying to escape the idea that we should
do something about trying to prevent a
pandemic from he's a doctor for people
that don't know by the way the
preponderance of evidence now points
towards this coming from the lab and
what you've done is change the
definition on your website to try to
cover your ass basically that's what
you've done you've changed the website
to try to have a new definition that
doesn't include the risky research
that's going on until you admit that
it's risky we're not going to get
anywhere you have to admit that this
research was risky the nih has now
rebuked them your own agency has rebuked
them
but the thing is is you're still
unwilling to admit that they gained in
function when they say they became
sicker they gained in lethality it's a
new virus that's not gain of function
watch what happens according to the
definition that is currently operable
you know senator
let's make it clear people who are
listening
the current definition watch his hands
was done over a two to three year period
by outside bodies including the nsa
speeded up through one point five two
conferences by the national academy of
science engineering medicine on december
2014 march 2016. we commissioned
external risk benefit assessment and
then in january of 2017 the office of
science and technology policy of the
white house issued the current policy
and coincidentally
on the same day the nih said that yes
there was a gain of function in wuhan
the same day the definition appeared the
new definition
what's going on and move on until you
accept it until you expect accept
responsibility we're not going to get
anywhere close to trying to prevent
another live league of this dangerous
sort of experiment you won't know that
it's dangerous and for that lack of
judgment i think it's time that you
resign thank you senator paul and i
would like um to give the time to doctor
there were so many things that are
egregious misrepresentation here madam
chair that i don't think i'd be able to
refute all of them but just a couple of
them for the lessons to hear from you
has said that i'm unwilling to take any
responsibility for the current pandemic
i have no responsibility for the current
pandemic the current pandemic okay
number two you said the overwhelming
amount of evidence indicates that's a
lab leak i believe most card carrying
viral phylogenists and molecular
virologists would disagree with you that
is much more likely even though we leave
open all possibilities it's much more
likely this was a natural occurrence
third you say we contested eighty
thousand animals and no animals have
been found with covingtons
first and third you made a statement
just a moment ago that's completely
incorrect where you say we continue to
support research at the wuhan institute
of virology
in august of last year no no your
statement says quote i wrote it down as
you were writing you continue to support
research at the wuhan institute of our
committee a month ago which said you
still trust the chinese scientist and
you still support the research over
there you said it a month ago well i
have allowed dr fauci to respond you've
had your time i'm going to give him he's
going to be dishonest he ought to be
jealous senator paul we will allow dr
fauci to respond after you've given
accusations like that dr fauci well i
don't have any more to say except to say
that as usual and i i have a great
respect for this body of the senate and
it makes me very uncomfortable to have
to say something but he is egregiously
incorrect in what he says thank you
history will figure that out on its own
turn to senator hassan thank you okay so
now here's the question would you give
this extremely high
turn off what's that oh
i'm going to close that buddy
you think that thing could lift my fat
ass i won't i want one of those
traffic
but listening to what just happened
right there do you believe fauci for
what he said do you believe him
it's hard for me man because i hate that
man with every fiber in my being sorry
why though why is that though why
because i think he's i think that
there's so much evidence to show that he
has lied
in so many different ways at so many
different varying stages that once you
lie in a situation like this and and
there's too many people out there that
that
brush it off and say well politicians
lie one he's not a politician he's not
supposed to be anyway he is but he's not
supposed to be and two in a situation
like this if you lie to cover your ass
once i can never trust you again you're
just gonna cover your ass cover your ass
cover your ass and if your job is more
important to you than your your
neighbors your countrymen if you've been
willing to watch what's happened to your
country for the last 20 months just to
save your own ass come on man i got
nothing for you bro and that's that's
not even getting into the more
conspiratorial stuff with the beagles
and everything like that you know you
know what's very weird to me
how the hell have we not started an
investigation on china how are we not
going after why is it so uncomfortable
to say you know there could possibly be
so so where i'm going with that is if
we're uncomfortable with that then
there's something that's being hidden
well if if we are so protective of not
wanting to go after somebody that cannot
stand what we stand for the china cannot
stand what we stand for and after all
the tariffs then all of a sudden we have
a pandemic to get rid of a guy you can't
stand because he figured out a way how
to make your life a living health
through the tariffs and we can't
investigate that even this is what jon
stewart asks on stephen colbert if we
can't investigate it that that's a
little bit too
uh uh uncomfortable what did the fbi
agent say about that conversation the
fbi fbi agent said uh his answer was
david remind me what he said he said i i
don't have enough information to make uh
statements i don't know everything about
this i said you know what since you run
a podcast i'd love to see you take an
extensive because there's billions of
people worldwide that would want to know
if you believe this situation or not
because that's your expertise so he said
well maybe we're going to do it on the
podcast so we'll see if they're going to
do it or not well would you agree these
types of conversations should be
consistent and
into perpetuity until some sort of like
i wish there was some sort of fact
checking that was going on there because
i didn't see a lot of
quivering or deflecting from fouchy i'm
not a huge fouchy fan but i'm not like
gerard i don't hate fauci i think he's
put in a difficult situation has he lied
has he i don't know i'm not going to be
like this is the way it is i don't know
okay i do appreciate the fact that rand
paul
is grilling him and holding him to
account
uh
look i don't also he's 80 freaking years
old he doesn't need this job he's the
most highest paid person in the
government why is he still doing it
that's okay that's a that's a very good
question i don't know i don't have that
answer i don't pretend to know lying or
he's bad at his job yeah so it's one of
two really bad options you're either
really bad at what you're doing or
you're lying
the answer is i don't know we i that's
why i appreciate what what rand paul is
doing as an annoying it is for fouchy
he's holding him to account is that his
wife is there anybody in this room or
watching right now anybody serious
question that thinks that we've been
told the truth as they know it the whole
time of course not
no i don't but also something that we
but if they lie to you this is once we
haven't had it why do you think they
would stop lying all of a sudden well
then why believe any politician ever or
anything or any spokesperson of anything
exactly so it's like everyone's lying
every
everyone lies every single day whether
it's a white lie or a full-on bold lie
it's these lies don't shut down most
lies don't shut down the world though i
will say one thing when this thing
happened did you think they actually
knew what was going to occur
meaning when fauci got the news of this
or any of these people
it would use a mask don't use a mask
it's not coming from muhammad it is
coming from one it came from a bad it's
not from a background i think they knew
immediately it didn't come from a damn
bat i think that that was nonsensical
from the jump
was it though like a guy ate a bat
and then the world got sick was a
nonsense i mean that was a nonsensical
thing from the beginning
i mean it was just insane oh by the way
the bat just happens to be
uh you know
well he's two and a half miles
sticking to his guns right now of course
because what what's the what's who did
you ask you asked that we were in an
interview once you asked the guy how
come how come they don't break rank how
come they don't because no one's
pressing them they no one's pressing
them
how did you get the mafia guys to turn
you threatened him with a hundred years
you pressed him
flip on his buddies what i don't get is
that we are what one-third of the
population of china one-third of the
population of india but yet we lead the
world
in covet
19 infections
because we're fat and unhealthy
also because we're accurately reporting
where i don't think these other
countries are yeah that's that's another
thing too as well so i you know it's uh
there's a profit incentive to be covered
positive don't forget that correct you
could have had the flu you could have
all these things it was eighteen
thousand dollars if you were back to
following the money back why people are
lying you follow the money trail the
other aspect too is if we do keep
digging up on china i think it starts
another war i mean this is some form of
war right here it's a biological war
then there's like an economic war and
then they're sending a supersonic
missile that nobody ever caught on radar
that could trigger so many different
events if we're boldly pointing a finger
at china it can drastically affect
america i mean look at right now
everybody's being affected by the supply
chain and things coming from china over
here to america i did i did i did a show
where uh i just randomly pulled things
from my kids uh uh toys pokemon cards
you know star wars lightsabers hey the
whole thing i had i brought it to the
office ten of the things all made in
china sure mrs scary part
matt
i'm at the point who cares we're the
united freaking states of america china
needs us we don't need sure they want to
play these games usa baby we
retract
we retract access to our market they
want to do what they want to do god
bless xi jinping
for years has had no problem
agitating and escalating with us and all
of a sudden the western world is
supposed to be like well go go for
midweek
circle the wagons get our industries
going get our people working for our
people bring pharmaceuticals back here
bring manufacturing back back here okay
all right and enough they want to play
their games and we're just supposed to
be like oh god what oh they're they're
very very strong they're very powerful
who are we yeah
we forgot who we are in this country man
to bring the manufacturing from china
into let's say mexico
india pat loves india i'm sure india
would love a couple trillion dollars i
think the philippines would love some of
those jobs as well come on all of which
we're supposed we're supposed to be
afraid yeah get out of here they want
the smoke
back-to-back world war champs buddy yeah
i i well you lost me at the last
sentence yeah i agreed with you until
then when you start talking like you run
have you run back palace on your hand
i'm not i'm not i'm not looking for you
to be
when you're rooting for a world war
that's where you're not rooting for a
world war what i'm saying is that they
want it we're not backing down enough
retreating that type of rhetoric is is
it listen
we do not want another cold war with
china we've had that with russia i don't
think that works out with anybody
uh we do need to have dialogue you don't
think the cold war worked out for the
united states of america yeah
well
other than the fact that we almost got
nuked i think it did work out no but
that's the whole point of uh
live in fear of an aggressor i'm not
saying that we should they're the
aggressor right now they're not they're
not retracting xi jinping's not saying
well god forbid we don't want a war
let's all live to no he's not he's like
our times now to hell with them and now
we're just supposed to be like well it's
their time it's their time god forbid we
do anything that's some never change
neville chamberlain [ __ ] when a bully
gets empowered he doesn't all of a
sudden become enlightened and go you
know what yeah let's let's back
more and more and more
that's have you ever seen any of these
uh chinese uh combat movies uh on
netflix have you ever stumbled across
some of those the new chinese rambo yeah
yeah
they're like they're like promoting
their military a lot you know how strong
their military is and their naval forces
and their special forces is interesting
they've been doing that lately
i don't know man you guys are going to
be going to stack up in the united
states spring baby come get some
look do i want one of course i don't
want war of course not but at the same
time i'm i'm sick of us
let me let me put it through this way
here's here's a you and i had a
conversation together about uh
mafia states and i said i want to know
where the issue was and you said well
everything the buck stops you know with
me etc said well we want to know and we
found out a lot right in the last four
weeks okay
now if we find out what happened then
what can we do
the next time around we make adjustments
that's all i care about right it's we
find out what took place so the next
time we're going through this we make
better decisions and better choices
knowing who does better under pressure
who's more for i'm going to come through
and deliver on my promises
i i i want to know what the hell
happened with covet because the last
here's here's what we still don't know
these guys are coming up till 2076. we
can't investigate what happened with the
pfizer okay we're not going to know what
happened with kids
we you and i have kids we're not going
to know what happened with kids
for 20 or 30 years you're not going to
know that we have no clue what's going
to happen so what those kids got to go
do what they've got to do because
somebody wanted to play the game that
they played yeah it doesn't sit well
with me so now here's the part we're not
pansies we're not softies we're not like
helpless to say oh my gosh this is not
fair no all i'm saying is i want to know
what the hell happened that's all i care
about if they were involved in this
fauci has got to want to know as much as
anybody else wants to know rather than
them saying no it wasn't china how do
you know it wasn't china
how do you know it's not china that's
the problem so if if he says well it's
david
no no no no it's not dave let's not
investigate david david didn't do it
david's not going with the onion how do
you know no it's not david
uh it's a little weird there you're so
protective of david but you're okay if i
go to tyler and mata yeah yeah
investigate but no no no no no david
didn't do it
how are you so certain
so that is a very very weird situation
for me i'm not saying it is or it's not
but it's very weird where you're all of
a sudden that's protective do they know
something about you that the rest of the
world doesn't know is there something
that if we would have found out about
you that you're gonna flip out i don't
know is there a reason why all these
interviews that was done with the judy
mykovitz got canceled is there a reason
why so many people want to hide anything
that's written about you is there a
reason why robert f kennedy the top
environmental attorney in america that
is rfk's son writes a book about you
that just came out as a top 10 book on
amazon why are so many people wanting to
find out more about you why don't people
trust you what what caused people to not
trust you what's going on here what what
is that that's what i want to know
certain jobs you shouldn't take without
knowing the heat that comes with it just
don't take it don't say i want to be a
c-suite oh really so you are now a
c-suite but you're [ __ ] bricks about
being a c-suite then don't freaking be a
c-suite go be a manager don't be a
c-suite i want to be a salesperson oh
really you're a salesperson but every
month you're asking for in advance
against your commission because you're
broke because you can't sell go back and
be an employee you want to be this
person that's going to be on it for the
entire time during the time like this
all the pressure is on you so i just
want to get to the bottom and see what
happened and whoever that screwed it up
you got to be held accountable whoever
did the right thing we got to turn them
into hero history books has to
turn the people that did the right thing
into a hero and if it's him let's do it
if we find out everything and he is
truly right i want this guy to have the
most ridiculous retirement celebration
people showing up because he did the
right thing but if he's not
and you were dividing america and
hurting us you got to go to jail buddy
100 percent you got to go pay the price
for it so is the organization that
should be investigating china and and to
your point why don't we hear about
that more often like is there
who who is the organ is not the who is
it the united states is it the world
health organization who is it that
should in fact be
investigating china combination and why
isn't it in the head you know front page
news every single day national security
advisor should be in the cia
yeah but like is there is there a
centralized power that should be doing
this is the world involved
there's a there's quite a few
organizations that could do this but
there's also a reason why maybe they're
not doing this first of all if they did
decide to do this you don't think behind
closed doors they're sitting there
saying hey 2 000 containers for 25 000.
we're going to have a fine christmas in
china you guys are not gonna have a good
christmas because we're making a gift
here in the toys here and all we have to
do is drive it over you guys need a ship
we don't need a ship we're fine you want
to do anything to us go right ahead
the world has empowered them so much
that they have so much leverage that
everybody's walking on eggshells making
sure
they don't screw up because they own
manufacturing they own the chips they
own everything
so many pharmaceuticals pfizer 80
you can't go on but percentage of acs
they make there's so many different
things they have control over this is
the world's fault this is this is
america's fault on the policies of how
they negotiated with china when they
were a small little not not a
population-wise but they were not a
superpower to not being who they are and
it's being ran by a guy like him who
can't stand america who can't stand rich
people who it has to be all about him
yeah
the world paid a price for it america
led the way because america is the
leader of the free world you made them
stronger now you're going to pay a price
for it a lot of people see themselves
very very rich in those deals and they
enrich themselves by selling out their
company listen say you got say you got
five sales people in your organization
one guy is an absolute um dirt bag okay
does shady business
steals all this stuff
if you
keep making him the hero over and over
and over and over and over again a year
two years three years five years from
now your company goes on because of him
it's not his fault it's your fault it's
your lack of paranoia where you empower
the wrong person you're paying a price
price for it you shouldn't have been
naive america became naive and they
empowered a communistic region what are
you doing empowering that country you
could have gone to india you could have
gone to so many different places to
empower why are you empowering somebody
whose philosophies are completely
opposing of our philosophies i don't
understand this if you're gonna empower
somebody we should at least have similar
values and principles
we don't have to have the same religion
you can be a buddhist you can be a
seven-day you can be a catholic you can
be a muslim you can't but if we both
have similar values and principles that
we follow by we ought to do business
together do you realize how completely
opposite communism and capitalism is
sure yeah sweatshops they got over there
people are working for two three cents
at that time or down you half a dollar
50 cents an hour they're this they're
working like they're destroying these
people but no let's keep producing
business over there because it's cheaper
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]
you